hey guys it's january twentieth I'm
chassis with your top five stories of
the week Mary what are you doing leavin
what do you mean you're leaving no you
can't go no no no no no what's this your
resignation letter nope nope not going
anywhere have like more coffee don't go
alright the news what was your favorite
news story this week tell me in the
comments below right now predict the
future before I even tell you first up
2016's best-selling games in the US were
revealed this week the NPD group
released its us sales report for
December and announce the top cell and
games for 2016 Call of Duty infinite
warfare came out on top for both
December and the entire year rounding
out the top five games of the year where
battlefield one at number two the
division at number three NBA 2k 17 at
number four and madden nfl 17 at number
five surprisingly two games released
before 2016 made it to the top 10 grand
theft auto 5 at number six and call of
duty black ops 3 at number eight read
the rest of the list and platform
specific list for December at gamespot
com next up the nintendo switch will not
have netflix or other streaming services
at launch seriously nintendo confirmed
that the switch will not have any video
game streaming services at launch in a
statement of videogamer.com the company
explained why and teased that streaming
services might come to the console
sometime after launch quote all of our
efforts have gone toward making the
nintendo switch system an amazing
dedicated video game platform so it will
not support any video game streaming
services at launch however support for
video game streaming services is being
considered for a future update the
switch launches at march third priced at
three hundred dollars next we found out
the switch vs wii u differences for
zelda breath of the wild breath of the
wild will have the same content and will
run at 30 frames per second on both
switch and wii u the switch version will
render at 900p on your TV but the wii u
version tops out at 720 the wii u disc
version also requires a 3 gigabyte
install and the special and master
editions are only available on the
switch just like the switch breath of
the wild will release on March third
next we got a new Pokemon
go update this week here's what it does
a new Pokemon go update arrived on the
17th with one notable change the
official patch notes explained that the
update changes distance tracking to
better account for GPS drift that's the
term for when your character shifts
location due to the GPS service on your
phone not always working as well as it
should also included in the update our
minor text fixes and Apple watch
functionality that displays the eggs you
obtain from Polk a stops and finally you
can now play as ariana grande in a final
fantasy game amazing after confirming
her involvement in final fantasy brave x
vs last year Square Enix and Gumi today
announced that an ariana grande
character is now available in the
free-to-play mobile game the look of the
character called dangerous ariana is
inspired by the pop singers trademark
bunny ears outfit to get the character
you need to complete the dangerous woman
tour stage though you can do this on
easy difficulty so no sweat and that's
our top 5 of the week and hey if you're
a resident evil fan be sure to check out
our gamespot studios about Resident Evil
we're talking to the resident evil 7
developers to see how their reimagining
the series subscribe for more and I'll
see you next week
[Music]